let's see if we can figure out the limit
of x over natural log of x as x
approaches one and like always pause
this video and see if you can figure it
out on your own
well we know from our limit properties
this is going to be the same thing as
the limit
as x approaches one of x
over
the
limit
the limit
as x approaches one of the natural log
of x
now this top limit the one i have in
magenta this is pretty straightforward
this if we had the graph of y equals x
that would be continuous everywhere it's
defined for all real numbers and it's
continuous at all real numbers and so
it's continuous the limit as x
approaches 1 of x is just going to be
this evaluated at x equals 1. so this is
just going to be 1. we just put a 1 in
for this x
so the numerator here would just
evaluate to a 1
and then the denominator
natural log of x is not defined for all
x's and therefore it isn't continuous
everywhere but it is continuous at x
equals 1. and since it is continuous at
x equals 1 then the limit here is just
going to be the natural log evaluated at
x equals 1. so this is just going to be
the natural log
the natural log of 1
which of course is 0. e to the 0 power
is 1. so
this is all going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to
if we just evaluate it 1
over
0.
and now we face a bit of a conundrum 1
over 0 is not defined if it was 0 over 0
we wouldn't necessarily be done yet
that's indeterminate form as we will
learn in the future there are tools we
can apply when we're trying to find
limits and we evaluate it like this and
we get zero over zero but one over zero
this is undefined which tells us that
this limit does not exist
so does
not exist
and we are done